[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute geht's ein französisches gericht
und frau betrat tui machen
irgendwie erinnert mich das immer an den
film the tree den kennt ihr bestimmt
auch mit dessen talent aus ich glaube
ich hat den schon tausend mal gesehen
rechte hatte wollte hatten langen
schwanz finden
ich glaube da muss mal wieder mit samira
angucken jedenfalls gibt es bei der tui
das ist ein gemüse gericht war es zuerst
gebraten und dann geschmort wird als dem
ofen zumindest bei mir und dieses
gericht kommt ursprünglich aus dem süden
frankreichs of nizwa aber wir werden bis
heute im süden deutschlands nimmt in
waghäusel zu bereiten
ich sage ich jetzt mal kurz die zutaten
für das ratatouille nämlich drei
zwiebeln 68 knoblauch 10 500 gramm
tomaten zucchinis eine rote und eine
gelbe paprikaschote und eine aubergine
ich habe ich noch 100 milliliter
olivenöl und jeweils einen esslöffel
oregano rosmarin und thymian etwas chili
das ist ein halber teelöffel ein
teelöffel salz einer prise zucker und
etwas pfeffer
ich habe jetzt das gemüse bereits
gewaschen und de zwiebeln geschält die
werden jetzt geschnitten und übrigens
ist das auch ein veganes gericht also
ich hab nämlich nur der einzige gemüse
letztlich die zwiebel und die schneide
ich jetzt nicht ganz fein sondern ich
halte sie und 4c units schneidig sie in
etwa 5 mm breite streifen
[Musik]
jetzt werden die knoblauchzehen fein
gehackt und zwar schneide ich sie in
scheiben
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich etwas olivenöl in einer
pfanne oder in einen großen topf zwei
drei bis vier esslöffel und da kommt die
zwiebel und knoblauch scheiben mit
raketen und die werden jetzt hier glasig
gedünstet das mache ich jetzt auf
mittlerer stufe und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal das restliche
gemüse schneiden und zwar nehme ich hier
die aubergine und der komplizierten der
strom weg und dann schneidest du erstmal
in drei teile hat muss nämlich etwas
einfacher mit viertel ich sehe und dann
halte ich dann habe ich nämlich so große
würfel
[Musik]
jetzt gibts die auberginen in einem sieb
und geht da noch salz drüber und
verlieren die dann dadurch etwas
flüssigkeit und auch ein bisschen die
bitterstoffe was jetzt hier an der seite
stehen und kann jetzt auch schon mal die
zucchini schneiden und die schneide ich
jetzt genau wie die auberginen auch in
würfel
[Musik]
die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen sind
glasig gedünstet nämlich einen
schmortopf das ist auch ein spargel
nicht und fühlen da jetzt die zwiebeln
und die knoblauchzehen mit rein denn das
gemüse wird jetzt alles separat
angebraten
ein bisserl auf dem boden verteilt und
dann gebe ich den deckel drauf und
stelle jetzt den sport talk show in den
backofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
und dann darf das da zehn minuten weiter
schmoren
als nächstes kommt jetzt noch mal
olivenöl in die pfanne ist etwa zwei
esslöffel und da gebe ich jetzt die
zucchinis mit rein
wir werden die jetzt etwa 12 minuten
gebracht und so brate ich dann auch
anschließend die paprika
[Musik]
die zucchini frau aus und füllt sie um
und da kann ich die paprika stücke auch
in zwei esslöffel olivenöl anbraten
[Musik]
die zwischenzeit muss sich jetzt um die
tomaten zu häuten und zwar könnt ihr das
jetzt entweder mit einem sparschäler
machen wenn ihr einen hut mit dem es
funktioniert bei mir geht es jetzt mit
den heute hat er diese gezeigt wie
klinge mal klappt es ganz gut oder er
übergibt sie wird etwa kochendem wasser
könnte dann anschließend heute
[Musik]
m
die zehn minuten sind vorbei kann sich
vorsichtig den deckel weg nehmen und
hier bereits die zucchini würfeln mit
dazu geben
jetzt kommt da bereits ein bisschen salz
drüber dann kommt da die paprika stücke
mit rein und werden auch gesalzen und
ich gebe auch hier schon ein bisschen
was von den kräutern mit rein
die vermisse ich vorher und auch etwas
pfeffer wird nämlich die auberginen
stücke und das sieht man jetzt auch die
haben richtig gute feuchtigkeit
rausgelassen aber damit ich jetzt das
essen nicht was er muss jetzt natürlich
das alles erst mal kalt abspülen und die
auberginen auberginen stücke ausdrücken
[Musik]
euro
m
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich noch das restliche
olivenöl und beraterin die auberginen
stücke an
und dann kann ich auch bereits die
tomaten in wirklich schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt will ich die auberginen stücke
direkt in den topf und dann kommen noch
die tomaten obendrauf
[Musik]
jetzt jetzt das rittertum gemüse nochmal
gewürzt mit pfeffer und dann auch mit
dem restlichen salz und dem chili den
restlichen gewürzen also den restlichen
kräutern und noch einer prise zucker da
ich jetzt tomaten drin hat gibt es gerne
zucker mit rein denn das hebt den
tomaten geschmack jetzt kommt der deckel
drauf das ist auch nicht mehr heiß und
da kommt die zimmer in den backofen bei
180 grad ober unterhitze und musste etwa
45 minuten schmoren und dadurch dass
sich das gemüse jetzt alles separat
angebraten habe hat das gemüse jetzt
diesen eigengeschmack und jetzt im ofen
verbinden sich dann die aromen und
schmeckt späteren richtig lecker
[Musik]
das ratatouille gemüse ist fertig das
ist jetzt moratorium nur ganz also
müsste es eigentlich auch nennen oder
ratatouille moto2 und es riecht wirklich
schon richtig lecker
ich habs jetzt aber auch etwa 20 minuten
abkühlen lassen ich möchte nicht dass
der rat sich jetzt verbrennt so ist uns
nicht richtig lecker martig schöpfte
jetzt ein bisschen was raus und das ist
nicht nur einfach gemüse kein fleisch
nein und das gemüse vorher alles schön
einzeln angebraten
ok also immer separat zu diensten
turrini aubergine zwiebel knoblauch und
tomate und paprika und sind auch für die
traditionellen gemüsesorten die da rein
gehören
okay wir sind wie das kräuter er mit
matze probieren
kräuter dapd gespannt ich zeige mich
noch mal ganz kurz hier
man sieht richtig die schönen kräuter
drüber und man merkt es ist es her nicht
zu weit noch bissfest aber ist es
morgens wie nah es darf auch weich sein
weil das wta 45 minuten geschmort und es
sehr trocken richtung deswegen ich komme
mal sofort das erkläre die sowieso
sternekoch kein sterne-koch dabei auf
den baugeld wahnsinn
also vielleicht könnte er mal so eine
weiße jacke anziehen und so ein richtig
auf auf ständig so richtig guck dir noch
einfach besser an und dann die arbeit
auf dem bau ging bei uns ist schon die
gabel ein seltenes potenzialwachstum
aufmerksam er
ich hole die auf jeden fall sondern
erfolgte jedenfalls wollte ich noch das
zu sagen wir können dieses gericht auch
gut vorbereiten ihr könnt nämlich alles
in einer pfanne eben anbraten oder im
topf und dann in den bräter eingeben und
dann zum beispiel kurz vorm fernseher
dann eben durch gaben und super
fleischersatz wirklich was hast du immer
mit deinem fleischersatz also für dich
ja die ganze welt fleisch oder seine
orte sich super an fleischesser wie ein
ich bin ich denke ich zum anderen setzt
aber aber ich finde es einfach toll weil
ich weiß von meinen freunden
ich habe sich freuen die sagen wenn ich
kein fleisch fertig sein und ich finde
das wird nicht heute gelungen ist bin
ich gar nicht also ich finde das kann
man so auf jeden fall passen zum
beispiel mit einem baguette dazu oder
mit nem kartoffelstampf dazu oder mit
reis dazu noch mit beilage dazu ja so
wird man also ich würde jetzt davon
jetzt werden machen oder als beilage
dann einfach ein schönes steak typisch
morath also weiter zu empfehlen
absolut absolut okay wenn ihr das rezept
name haben sollte dann geht auf meinem
blog cell.de förderlich wie essen das
jetzt noch und ich denke wir werden
jetzt noch den film ratatouille ich
zusammen angucken oder mit samira sich
so eines dieser finden müsst ihr erstmal
sehen also desto goldes ich finde
richtig schön französisch noch einen
guten appetit und schön war es beim
nachmachen für meinen wir sehen uns das
nicht normal und bis zum 8
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die aubergine und da
sieht man jetzt auch die haben ein